>>Probably the most important
thing for kids growing
up today is the love
of embracing change.
>>I mean, the catch
for preparing students
for the 21st century workforce
is "How do you get kids
that have curiosity and
a questing disposition?"
We have called it in the past
"the gaming disposition."
If you look at the disposition
of hardcore gamers such as World
of Warcraft, massive multi-player
games, the surprising thing
that you find, contrary to what
people think, is these kids,
first of all, are incredibly
bottom-line-oriented.
They want to be measured,
because they want
to see how much they're improving.
And in fact the most common
mantra of a real gamer is
"If I ain't learning, it ain't fun."
And how do they constantly
keep learning is
because basically they are
embracing change, leveling-up,
doing higher-order tasks, or
the game itself is changing,
or they change the game in terms
of the strategies they want
to experiment with and
so on and so forth.
And in fact if you think of this
questing disposition you end
up embracing change,
not running from change.
>>Coming from that gaming
disposition I became very intrigued
when I landed here in Maui.
It turns out that my neighbor turns
out to be a 20-year-old
kid moderately world-famous
in the surfing world
named Dusty Payne.
And what got interesting to us is
that Maui has never produced
a world-class champion before.
They basically come from Oahu,
from the North Shore
and so on and so forth.
But all of a sudden four kids make
it big, big time here in Maui.
You say "What happened?"
>>And it turns out that if you kind
of meet these kids they have all
come together very much like a guild
in World of Warcraft, and what they
do is they compete with each other
and they collaborate with each
other incredibly intensely.
They think up a new move, they dash
down the hill, they try it out,
they take their video
cameras with them.
They're videoing each other.
They dash back up here.
They start kind of analyzing
what worked, what didn't work,
build new ideas, dash down
the hill again, try it out.
And then what they start doing is
they start looking at, of course,
all the other people
surfing around the world,
which they get from YouTube.
They have all this kind of stuff.
They start picking up
new moves like that.
That's a kind of interesting way
that digital media has enhanced the
ability of these surfing kids to pick
up all kinds of new tricks.
And I can actually show you
how a particular move now
on a surfboard takes about
48 hours to propagate
around the world before
all the key surfers
of the top edge are trying
it out themselves, okay?
And of course any time something
changes they're the first to try it
out and to appropriate
it, so these kids live
for picking up something new.
They live for trying
out something new.
And some of this stuff, by the
way, is moderately dangerous.
So these are high-cost mistakes,
but the passion that they have
to do this is really awesome.
Well, guess what.
The passion that I see
in the World of Warcraft
of the high-end high
performers is also awesome,
but it doesn't stop there.
If you look at the artists,
if you look at the musicians,
if you look at the dancers, if
you look at athletics in general
and to the extreme edge what you
have is kids that are turned on.
And when they get really turned
on in the right context
there's almost no stopping.
>>Any interest that any kid has,
I am sure there's already existing
out there a passionate community
of interest group or a community
of practice that you can try to join.
And in fact going back to Jean Lave's
classic work in situated learning,
maybe the learning has to do
with learning how to join,
or you learn to join, and once
you join now you marinate in that,
and learning isn't
something you do consciously.
It is something you absorb.
And so there's something that most
serious learning often happens
through an osmosis process
that once I dwell in the set
of the experiences things
are getting integrated
in my head not necessarily
consciously,
because there's a tremendous amount
of tacit knowledge that I'm kind
of being exposed to in
these kind of communities.
And I just start to integrate,
assimilate, let things gel,
and it's not particularly conscious.
>>What makes these ideas so
relevant now is in a world
of rapid change any particular
skill that I've learned is apt
to have a moderately
short shelf-life.
So what I really need to do is to
know how to create context for myself
that I keep scaffolding and
learning and accelerating what I know
to increase my own performance.
And so there's a sense of what
I'm doing becomes a platform
for doing something new,
learning something new
and becoming even better and
actually moving potentially
into quite a different type of field.
So it's kind of like suddenly
now I'm looking at trajectories
through life space as
opposed to fixed points.
>>I think the construct that
has been most overlooked now
on the 21st century and
maybe in the 20th century
as well is the power
and importance of play.
That is to say, how do I take an idea
and how do I kind of play with it,
how do I tinker with it, how
do I come to make it personal,
how do I come to own it, how
do I dwell in the idea itself?
And this plays out,
for example, in poetry.
How do I find that magic combination
of now that phrase or that line
in a poem says exactly
what I mean deep inside me?
Likewise, how do I work with
engineering systems and kind
of see how things couple together?
How do I tinker with these devices,
things as simple as radios and stuff
like that or microphones
on cameras to kind
of really understand what's the
way that these systems really work?
And how do I kind of learn that by
experimenting with the stuff myself?
Because you've got to learn
that not everything works.
In fact most things don't work.
And if the first thing that happens
when something doesn't work is it
frightens you, then you're not going
to be very willing to embrace change.
But if you realize that when things
don't work, which is almost always,
you can get in there and figure
out how to tinker with these things
and just absorb what happens,
very often when you're tinkering
it doesn't make pure logic sense.
It's something you begin to feel
in your hands as much as your mind.
Tinkering brings thought
and action together
in some very powerful, magical ways.